but um how did you guys find uh
australia that's that's what i want to
know absolutely [ __ ] loved australia
yeah i found like my long-lost second
home in australia man it was like i've
said this so many times before but i
australia to me was like the uk except
everyone there was just way happier
that's because the weather's better i
guess i don't know the wildlife is
cooler the weather is better um you know
things a lot more things to kill you
if you built the uk from like like a new
fresh account yeah
in a good climate right
it's like if you build the uk for a new
fresh account but you've played the game
before yeah yeah yeah so you know
exactly
no because like i've never you know
truth be told i've never felt like super
patriotic about australia like you know
i love australia don't get me wrong it's
my home but it's like i've never been
like yeah aussie aussie aussie until the
boys came to australia and i was like
do you like it
please please
would you please say you like this place
thank god we did it we did australia we
did it yeah it was honestly i don't
really have any complaints about
australia wow i'm i'm like i'm like
trying i'm like trying to wrap my brain
over something i can complain about
because we're [ __ ] british and we
need to complain about everything and i
guess the only thing i complain and i
can complain about is the lack of
anything to complain about basically
like every every australian was like oh
so sorry for the weather so sorry for
the weather i was like what what why are
you apologizing for the weather this is
[ __ ] amazing weather
it was a bit of [ __ ] what are you
talking about it was a bit it's a bit
cloudy
yeah i think it's just a shame because
we were really tired yeah so we couldn't
really like have a hundred percent i i
want to have a vacation there for sure
yeah oh yeah yeah i feel
especially when it comes to sydney
because you know we were there mostly
for you know the convention yeah yeah
twitch stuff and stuff like that yeah i
feel you guys didn't really get to have
like a proper view of
sydney i guess i went to a reptile park
i feel like you and sydney didn't really
get to see like actual sydney sydney
yeah like but i mean you at least you
got to experience melbourne yeah because
i after the uh after smash tour and i
traveled to melbourne because we had
some uh i have some family there who
i've never visited in australia
um
and it was [ __ ] fantastic because
they live right like they live more on
the outskirts of melbourne they live
near yarra valley which is basically
just a bunch of [ __ ] wineries so i
was me and sydney just had a whole
[ __ ] field day just going around
wineries one day they took us around
you're engaging in an australian
activity yeah yeah that is yeah wineries
is an australian activity absolutely
exactly how could i complain when we
just like what we did to be shown around
was being shown around a bunch of
wineries and just trying a bunch of
[ __ ] wines beaches wineries and
breweries that's that's just australia
saw some uh saw some kangaroos on a golf
course that was that was weird oh yeah
yeah i got to like i went up to like
little baby kangaroos you can like pet
them and stuff yeah that was fun yeah
yeah like joey's yeah little girls yeah
see seeing kangaroos never heard that
one before
seeing kangaroos like up close in real
life for the first time um
just made me like just confirmed with me
how [ __ ] batshit natural selection
was in australia like i just what
[ __ ] happened to natural selection
australia i don't get it that's what
happens when you have a server
completely isolated from any other
server sure like even just looking at
kangaroos right i'm like how the [ __ ]
did
what what what happened in the history
of kangaroos to lead your evolution
because you know basically everywhere
else in the world because what i've
realized is that kangaroos are basically
just australian deers right
they're basically just australian deers
but like in every other in in every
other side of the world
animals just decided okay four legs
walking on four legs that's the matter
that's the most effective meta and then
all the way in [ __ ] australia
kangaroos are like that's just [ __ ]
bounce everywhere right
does not even [ __ ] walk let's bounce
everywhere like what the [ __ ] happened i
mean if you're talking about dumb
[ __ ] evolution the koala is like the
king is like [ __ ] stupidity
like
like when you hear like when i did the
irl stream we got to hear about the
koalas and literally every single koala
attribute had like 20 caveats right they
were like so goddamn dumb they all they
could only eat one [ __ ] plant the
eucalyptus tree and the best part is is
that if you take the eucalyptus leaf off
the tree they don't know what it is yeah
they're like i can't eat this yeah what
is this what's this leaf what is it i
don't know what this is they don't eat
it how how and also the reason why they
sleep for 16 hours a day is because the
toxins in the eucalyptus leaf basically
act the same way that marijuana does to
humans so they're just stoned yeah
that's what i realized koalas just are
just the [ __ ] stoners of the world
yeah they're just stoner bits yeah
that's all they are and the babies have
to eat the mom's poop right yeah yeah
like i found this out at the smash con
panel yeah where koalas have to like
when koalas are born the mum needs to
eat the eucalyptus leaves and [ __ ] it
out yeah right because the because the
baby's stomach isn't strong enough to
break down the toxins of the eucalyptus
tree because it's technically toxic yeah
how the [ __ ] did this animal survive in
australia one of the most dangerous
places in the world in terms of wildlife
how how the [ __ ] does that happen you
know like they literally lucked out by
putting all their points into cuteness
if humans didn't exist they'd be [ __ ]
man oh yeah absolutely cuteness only
from a distance though because like i
don't know if you ever got like did you
ever get to get like really close to a
coil yeah i got to touch it it doesn't
not smell like [ __ ] oh yeah they all
smelled really old they smell [ __ ]
horrible actually yeah yeah well yeah
they they're literally born eating [ __ ]
so of course they're gonna smell like
[ __ ] as well like there are a lot of
maintenance to keep them happy i think
as well yeah otherwise they'll just die
they're just like ah [ __ ] it i'll die
yeah guess i'll die
literally they will they're too stoned
to care man
[Applause]
delicious oh it's hot holding back like
you guys i feel like you guys didn't
even get to see like the truly weird
animals that we have no we didn't even
like we we only saw your base level
animals and those were [ __ ] weird
enough yeah because i remember you were
freaking out about like all the wild
cockatoos right oh yeah yeah the birds
are crazy yeah yeah but it's absolutely
insane also birds [ __ ] they're cute
as [ __ ] yeah they're awesome yeah we
need more exciting wildlife you guys are
you guys freaking out about the iverses
was my funniest thing ever because we're
on the pigeon matter in the uk yeah
we've been on the pigeon meta for that
like
like hundreds of years the pigeon and
seagull meta yeah true true i mean we
have seagulls as well
even your seagulls look way more
aesthetic than rc goals really yeah yeah
they do they do what do your seagulls
look like hideous
hideous i don't look at a seagull and go
like damn that's a good looking bird
though i didn't do that until i went to
australia and saw your seagulls they're
so like slim their beaks are nice and
polished they're actually clean
and i'm just like what the [ __ ] are the
seagulls in the in england be eating you
know these seagulls been growing up from
the [ __ ] streets well they fight each
other yeah they fight each other every
day in the uk they fight
yeah but gone telling me about uh the
ivis's was so funny yeah those are weird
i never thought about how weird that
must be to someone outside of australia
because i'm just so used to it what are
the ibis again the bean chicken or the
bin chickens yeah yeah yeah i just like
it's this by the way for those of you
who've never been weird
it's just like why like i'm surprised
that like
australia like allowed them to exist
yeah
because they feel like i feel like when
the animal gets too big
it just gets like destroyed yeah it gets
destroyed yeah because i said the reason
why we can't [ __ ] keep tigers alive
because they're too big and easy to
[ __ ] capture yeah because again i
feel like it's too big of a bird it's
not nimble enough it looks so weird as
well yeah yeah literally like i remember
i remember like the first time i saw it
was actually walking right in the center
of the streets of sydney oh so many of
them yeah there's so many because
normally i'm used to just seeing pigeons
and seagulls in a city i'm not and then
i suddenly turned the corner and this
massive [ __ ] bird with a really long
thick like no a really long slender
narrow beak and i'm like what the [ __ ]
is that what the [ __ ] is that can they
fly yo is that a pokemon
uh nothing honestly is there any like do
they do they have some ecological
service that they do for the
what are they they they they eat the
trash i guess oh that's why they're
called bin chickens because they're
always rummaging around because they're
like they're basically the rats of
sydney do you like spiders get rid of
flies and stuff yeah yeah yeah what
would have been chickens do yeah i don't
know what
what have been look up look up the
purpose of an ibis
like what what ecological role did they
serve in the hierarchy i don't know like
to entertain us yeah yeah funny [ __ ] to
entertain to entertain foreigners
man what the hell is that
yeah no like every time i don't know
because i think i'm just so used to it
that like every time if i'm like eating
outside or something and there's just a
bunch of ibises like
walking around i'll just be like
[ __ ] off yeah yeah you know because like
i don't i haven't really ever seen or
heard of an ibis like attacking someone
or like someone getting hurt
oh they got a long basically just
[ __ ] stuff you should speak out the
way it's like
just grab it by the beach
[Laughter]
i don't know do you know what it is
i figured this out okay
what it is
everything we hate gets rid of another
insect i don't think i've ever seen an
ibis on a farm though they're always
like near the coast aren't they because
they're like just like
me i just discovered these things were a
month ago i don't know like they're in
this they're in the middle of the
[ __ ] city i don't see a farm in the
middle of the city